[Music]
[Music]
look at me now look at me now look at me
now hey where you going come on it's
like meeting the bed of my dreams and
the meeting is beautiful why isn't it
just shitty don't you think
it's not it's just a fortune you don't
know you're beautiful but now you're not
so beautiful what you're not supposed to
know I'm trying to find the words to
describe this girl without being
disrespectful again lady she's such a
beautiful person I just want a facebook
friend request her and it gives us hard
[Music]
I set fire to the Ring watch it poor and
burn up your face I will smile while you
die cuz I heard you screaming out
[Music]
all of the lace globe light street light
spotlight blood like Bud Light Christmas
lights buzz lightyear halogen lights
leds you make me come
you make me complete you make me
complete my sentences jeans be your
Teenage Dream tonight no that is not
what I mean I am over 18 none of the
whole age tonight I got 99 problems but
a [ __ ] ain't one like traffic was
really bad this morning hey I got
student loans I still gotta pay back I'm
trying to repair the relationship with
my father spiders spiders are just kind
of a problem in general I kind of find
myself compared my foot though there's a
lot
[Music]
I listen to priests and then I take
Union I only come here on holidays oh my
god so bored this is a journey sign hit
me baby one more time oh it's okay cut
another one my anaconda don't my
anaconda don't my anaconda don't get
here to international pet laws oh she's
out you uh just run one one the world is
plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because if I can't have you no one like
brights flashlights those little Chinese
lantern things candles yes
that's all of the lights oh the Sun